- On this episode, my
father-in-law comes on to
hawk his book.
(upbeat music)
- You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody
this is Gary Vay-nerchuk
and this is episode 153
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
As you can see, a rare situation,
by the way, we're doing
a double header today.
We're doing a double header today Peter.
I'll introduce Peter in a second.
We're doing a double header
today, so that's the first
time we've ever done that.
I like the fact that
DRock and Staphon are both
gonna actually have to
work India, that's good for
a change right?
And we will be editing
it up, and I'm excited,
are you guys,
I guess we can release them
very similar at the same
time, I'm excited about that,
but Peter, why don't you
tell the Vayner Nation
who you are.
- Hello everybody, this is Peter Kline,
and yes I really am Gary
Vay-ner-chuk's father-in-law.
- It's true.
- In this episode, I'm glad
to say we're gonna reverse
the rolls a bit, and we're
gonna reverse Gary into
moving from Mr. Answer
man, to Mr. Question man.
- Okay.
- But before that--
Do you know this India?
- [India] Yea.
- Okay good, here we go.
- You gotta be flexible in our business.
- Yea.
- Before we ask Gary to
maybe ask a couple questions
of why I'm really here
sitting in on this version,
I want to ask Gary, maybe
a bit of an introspective
question, building on a
question asked by Mark Cuban--
- Okay.
- In episode 151.5.
- Yea.
- I might be accurate or not--
- 150.5?
- When he wanted to know, and
I think he basically asked
Gary, "Gary when you interview talent--
- Yes.
- You know, "What are a few
of the key questions you would
"ask in almost every interview?"
- Yes.
- So my question to you Gary,
is really three parts, the
first two are pretty fast.
In your history--
- Yes.
- From a kid on--
- Through today--
- Yes.
- Was there ever an
individual guy or gal--
- Yes.
- Who you think intensely disliked you?
Yes or no?
- That knew me?
- I would use the word,
almost, hate, but I would
go short of that, intensely,
oh that you think disliked you?
- That knew me for more than a second
or just came across me--
- Could care less.
- Well, the answer is a ton of people.
- Okay.
- Second part of it, give
me the name of one of them.
- I have no--
- Just first name alone.
- Oded.
- Oday?
- Oded?
- O-D-E-D, Oded.
- Oded? Oded?
- Oded.
- Gary's not here.
- Okay.
- What do you dislike with Gary?
- Oh Peter here's the thing,
so we're in second grade,
and Gary's very popular,
and everybody likes him,
and that bothers me so
I'm not gonna invite him
to his birthday party,
to my birthday party
because, I'm Oded, I'm jealous
of his enormous charisma.
- Okay.
Well my followup to that
was basically gonna be that
you scored fine on that question on
passion and transparency.
- Yes.
- I'm not quite sure on
the transparency side.
- Well I think that's the truth.
- Well if that's the truth
then introspective wise
that's fine.
- Peter, hold on, I'm gonna jump in here.
Guys, I adore my father-in-law,
let me tell you a fun fact.
Peter why don't you, actually
I'm gonna play a little bit
here as host, here's a little fun fact.
This is gonna blow a lot
of people's minds away.
You know, you were a
tremendously successful
marketer, and you once
were involved in the naming
rights of a football stadium when you
were an executive, true?
- True.
- Why don't you tell the Vayner Nation
what stadium that was.
- Gillette Stadium, New England Patriots.
A couple of us went
there in very early 01.
- Can you (beeping) believe this?
- Sorry.
- So, I still made the cut to get on
The #AskGaryVee Show, and the
headline was we didn't even
know there was a stadium
being built at the time,
was working on a turnaround
at the Gillette Company
and maybe a year into the
turnaround, the Craft family
approached us, actually a
software company, CMGI I think
may have gone from--
- Bailed.
- $180 a share, down to $5 or $10.
They had bought the
rights to the new stadium,
and before the stadium
opened, they wanted out,
so to make a long story
short, we were able to get the
naming rights to Gillette Stadium.
So, Vayner Nation, you
probably will find this
super fascinating Peter,
when I met Peter's lovely
daughter Lizzy, I was very
much in the wine business.
Peter was actively one of the
top executives at Gillette.
Peter didn't you guys like,
didn't the deal of selling
Gillette fall through on
the night of our wedding.
Isn't there some funny story like that?
- That's right, originally--
- Is that why you missed
the whole wedding?
- No, that was public domain, but--
- Okay good, shew.
Thank God, sorry big guy.
- They decided to walk for
a few reasons, and then
they revisited about 4 to
6 weeks later, it was 05.
- That was the best day of
your life right, when you knew
that your daughter was
marrying such a top class
human being, that must have
been a big night for you.
- Well that was a big
night, but the bigger night
was when we got to know
you before the big night.
- Which was when?
- Without giving to much
away here, I kind of knew
Gary was a wine expert when
on the very first time we
ever met was at a dinner here
in Manhattan, and I came in
with a bottle of wine
in a brown paper bag.
Halfway through the meal--
- This is my father-in-law.
- When the wine expert,
you know basically told me
he knew every wine in the
world, and I said well
tell me who made this one
and I pulled at a bottle
and on the front label it
said Major League Baseball,
special edition kind of thing,
and without even turning
around the bottle, Gary
nailed who made it,
and where it was made--
- Thanks PK.
- And then finally the
second meeting was when I
drove up to my home to have dinner.
- Yes.
- And I knew Gary was going
to be there for dinner
with my daughter, and as
I drive up to the house,
I'm driving up and I see the identical
car I'm driving, color, type--
- It's so weird.
- And I was convinced when
I walked inside that Gary
rented that car.
(laughing)
- To try to make--
- A good impression.
- And it was his actual car.
- Well listen--
- Thanks for the time today.
- Yea, as you can imagine, what an
unbelievable, you know,
when you get to marry
someone, you're marrying
their family as well,
and I couldn't have gotten
luckier with Lizzy and
her family, Peter being
at the forefront of that.
Obviously as my career took a
different change and got into
this corporate marketing
world, this is literally,
you gotta look it up, I
mean the guy's got a book.
I mean, I don't know if
it's selling as many copies
as the books that I tend to sale Peter,
you know I tend to be a
little bit competitive with
this stuff.
- Yea, I didn't notice.
(laughing)
But what's kind of interesting,
this is a book that three
of us wrote.
It came out in June from
McGraw Hill, and we did it for
a variety of reasons.
I'll just briefly tell
you what it's about.
No we didn't sell 60 or 70,000 presale,
although it came out in
mid June and we were told
that it's in its second
printing, got it kicked in
in early September.
- Nice job.
- Now, we don't know if they
printed 9 copies the first
round or how many copies, but
so be it, it's in its second printing.
- Listen, I think, India,
you have questions.
Peter, you don't have questions do you?
What are you doing here?
By the way, this is what's
so amazing about you and I.
Like you, look at, Peter,
you literally laid out what
you were gonna say.
This is where we differ quite a bit.
- This is a difference.
- This is a difference
between the two of us.
- The discipline of the older generation--
- Classic, he's classic, he's classic.
- who protects himself
and prepares in advance
versus the 118% left brain
driven younger generation.
- Peter, I pretty old compared
to the people that are
watching, just so you know.
- That's probably true.
- Yea, look at these youngsters.
How old are you Staphon?
- [Staphon] I'm 24.
- Staphon 24. India?
- [India] 25.
- India's 25. DRock?
- [DRock] 24.
- Look at this.
- Well, in the not to distant
future you might move out
of the millennial definition.
- I'm not in it right now.
- That's right.
- That sucks, but anyway, are you asking,
did you literally bring questions
or can we get into the--
- No, no, no--
- We can get into the show?
- Yea we can get into the show.
- We'll talk a little more
about the book, cause I'm here
to make sure the Vayner
Nation buys 58 million copies
of it, but India, India,
let's get into the show.
You ready PK?
- Sorry.
- We're both gonna answer, we're both
gonna answer here.
- Good, I'm ready.
- I mean, we'll play around.
Let's see what happens here, we spent a
billion minutes--
What's that?
Oh you did?
India is very, you know, she's sharp.
She's a creator, left
brain, 118%. Alright, go ahead.
- [Voiceover] Kyle asks, "As
someone who's about to turn 30
myself, what was the most
important thing you did
in your 30s to change your future?
- PK why don't you take that.
He's about to turn 30.
- That's a great question,
and the answer is, I took a
deep breath, stepped back,
and I said to myself,
where did I kind of want to be in the
next 10 to 20 years then.
I actually was working at Gillette.
I worked there twice and
this was 72-78 and I took
a step back and I said you
know, I wanted to be in
a position between the ages
of 32 to 35, where I can
make a decision to either stay
corporate America on a fast
track and doing all those things etc.
or shift gears and go into
a small start up, or smaller
business environment and write
a couple of my own patents.
A bit of an entrepreneurial
spirit, but I wasn't in a
position where I really had those choices.
I wasn't getting
inundated by smaller start
ups or new ventures.
I so I said you know what,
and I love Gillette they were
doing great, and they were
by me and everything
that counted, and I said
you know, I gotta get into
the New York area, and I
made a decision to move into
New York, with a large company
whom I communicated with
and said hey for 3 to 5 years,
I'm gonna beat the bushes
and see if I want to stay
or go into small business.
So that's kind of when I
stepped back and I said
and the rest is history.
- That's cool.
So, Peter was there, because
I married Lizzy when I was
28, turned 29 on our wedding night,
and so he saw this, which a
lot of you have heard before,
which is right at 30 I kind of
freaked out a little bit and
started really putting
the pedal to the metal,
started Wine Library TV right
after it, and as much as
I worked and as intensely
as I worked in my late 20s,
30 started the process of this
insanity that I'm executing
against now.
So, I just wanna buy the
Jets, but I didn't think I was
going fast enough, and so I
also took a step back and said
where am I gonna be in 10 or
20 years, let me make sure
my behavior maps it.
So, I think if you're entering
your 30s, I think it's really
smart to think about your 40s and 50s.
- So what Gary does on
intuition and gut, and heart,
and passion, I kind of did
over my career, maybe in a
little more disciplined,
little more balanced,
left brain, right brain way,
and it was a driver of why
we decided to write the
book, Think to Win, was to
try to bring some very
simple concepts and how tos
in the world of strategy
and execution to folks who
are working in small,
medium, large, companies,
public or private, even in
the not for profit sector,
where they can take a step
back and say hey look,
here are a few principles,
a few how tos, to get folks
aligned, fact based--
- Yep.
- Not myth based, and get
aligned on key issues,
key opportunities, and how do we execute.
Yogi Berra, who I was a
big fan of, and yes I do
have a signed picture from
Don Larson and Yogi Berra.
- Cause all of you were curious.
- Curious of that, who said,
"A good batter will always be
"a good pitcher, and vice versa."
- He is the best.
- I'm a believer in good
strategy always drives
good execution, and vice
versa, and that's kind of
what this book is about,
a more disciplined way
to kind of those how tos to let some power
strategic thinking can work.
- Tremendous right hook
Peter, let's go India.
- [Voiceover] Ryan asks, "How
do you deal with drama in
"the workplace, and how do
you avoid having more drama?"
- PK, drama in the workplace.
How much were you, as an
executive in corporate America
into HR like stuff, or did
you kind of let the pros handle that?
- I loved that area.
I was into it.
- I believe that by the
way, I know this guy.
- I was Mr. Anal Retentive.
- Me too.
- So, I kind of got my
fingers dirty, I knew
when to step in--
- In the anal retentiveness?
- But at the end of the day, jargon aside,
and I'm a believer of with whom you go is
more important than where you go,
I got heavily vested in the HR side,
because it didn't make any
difference what kind of
idea you might have,
start up or big company, big brands, small
brands whatever, but
whatever you're working on
combined with no matter how
much capitol you may have,
working capitol from start
up business or whatever,
at the end of the day, if you
didn't have the right people
or the right team in place--
- You're dead.
- Game over, and so--
- I believe that so much.
I don't think there's any Lakers,
there's Kobe and Shaq
era and then there's not,
and then you know, like
Stephan who's a Lakers fan,
he then becomes a Golden
State Warriors fan
because he's just
bandwagon, but most people
you know I've talked plenty
about HR, I want to get this
thing moving, I want some
speed India, let's go
to the next one.
- [Voiceover] James asks,
"Banks are old, stiff, and have
"largely the same messaging, safety.
"Is their sheer size saving
them from disruption for now?"
- Yea, I'll jump in on this
one because I'm spending a lot
of time with Silicon
Valley and that's really,
what's going on in
Silicon Valley now with
start ups that are looking to
attack banks, and if you look
at what's going on in general
with like Venmo and so many
other things that we're
living through, yea I mean,
I think banks have enormous
infrastructure and have
a value prop, but there's
enormous amounts of destruction.
I think the question alludes
to a marketing message,
and I think it's actually gonna be more
of a utility message.
When you start layering,
you know it's funny,
BitCoin has been not a top
of mine in the start up world
recently, but block chain
mentality and just the
innovation around financing
and the financial sector
is going to be pretty aggressive.
I actually think a lot of
bank's messages are not
necessarily just about safety.
I think it's about creating
indulgence and empowering you
to do the things that you want to do.
I've watched a lot of
the banking messaging,
as we start planning on
getting into a couple of
clients in that sector.
I think what's way more
important is that bank's brands
in our society are very poor,
because of what happened with
the Wall Street melt down
and things of that nature,
and I think a lot of banks
have been very slow to
properly transition to mobile
and so there's a lot of
white space and a lot
of innovation coming that, and it's funny
I can see the sharks circling around the
banking sector in SF
and it'll be interesting
for the next decade.
Keep it going.
- [Voiceover] Alex asks, "What
do you want to be remembered
"for the most?"
- Go ahead PK.
- Helping people to be
the best they can be,
family and otherwise.
- That's awesome.
For me, there's a lot
of different things that
I think about, but one of the
things that I really want,
I talk a lot about guilting
everybody I ever meet
to coming to my funeral.
I'm very passionate about bringing more
value to people than they brought to me.
One of the things I
admire so much about my
father-in-law Peter, is,
it's scary to me how many,
we're different clearly in
certain ways, but boy do
we have a lot of similarities,
and when I started to
get to know it was
interesting to me how his
wife Ann, who's amazing,
would talk about him,
I was like hmm, that's
me, that's what I like.
I like that everybody comes to
me for help and I help them,
and all those things, and
so that's what I would say,
51-49, that I gave more to
them in our relationship
than they gave to me.
That said, if you agree
with me, I think I better
rethink my position.
- Okay.
- Groucho Marks, 1938, duck soup.
Next question.
- Peter, good news, this
audience doesn't even
know my 1990--
- They don't even know
who Groucho Marks is.
- Do you know who Groucho Marks is?
- [India] Yea.
- Okay good, Staphon tell the truth, no.
DRock, no.
Peter, Peter, they didn't even know who
Samantha Fox was.
- [India] Well that's different.
- Do you know who Samantha Fox is?
- Yea (mumbles).
- Yea I know, these are
generational things.
- [India] You can't compare Samantha Fox
and Groucho Marx.
- Yes, Groucho Marx was much more classic,
I agree with, India--
- Headline is folks, if you don't know who
Groucho Marx is, Google
him, and look him up.
- Google him, let's go.
- Last one from Stephan.
- Stephan!
- [India] Not this one.
- Oh.
- [Voiceover] Stefan asks,
"Gary, you talk about hustle
"a lot, but what cost did you
have to pay to get here now?"
- Peter, you worked really hard.
- That's a great, I would
say, at the end of the day,
there doesn't have to be a
cost, and I really believe that.
- Hmm, you got everyone's attention.
- You're talking to a guy
who kind of spent a career
maybe averaging a number
of hours say almost
6-1/4 to 6-1/2 days a week,
12-14 hours average days,
over an entire career, having said that--
- You're giving a lot of
insight to why Lizzy is able
to deal with my insanity.
- Beyond multitasking
and learning how to do
all this stuff, when again,
you take a deep breath
along the way, step back, the
things that make a difference,
and the things that count
that you want to focus on,
to me, family first,
and so I always planned.
I was traveling a lot, half my
career was in the consulting
business, and I traveled a
lot, but I always tried to
do day trips to get back
in time for a late dinner,
whatever, be there when
the kids took baths,
managed little league teams, my son--
- How was Alex Kline as a
little league baseball player?
- He was all defense.
(laughing)
A little offense, but --
- Yes, on the record Alex eat it.
- He held his own, and he was a starter.
- Okay, all defense.
- You make time and you
try to balance it out,
so I don't know if there were
any real trade offs on a day
in and day out basis, doesn't have to be.
If you let what your focused
on solely run your life,
there will be usually
people, family, relationship
trade offs.
- I fully believe in that.
I think that the practical
level is that probably you and I
got to spend a little less time,
what we gave up was our
passion for business
or our careers, probably
came at the expense of some
other potential, hobbies,
and other leisures, that it
didn't come at the expense
of the family, but you
maybe never developed your
golf game, or your tennis
game, or fishing, or other
things that could have been
interesting to you in your life.
- That's good enough.
- That's what I can feel.
I mean I've got the Jets,
so I've got a thing for me,
but I definitely, I would be
very interested in all these
other little things, but I
punt them for the business.
- Great point, may or may
not be necessarily relevant
I think because again, when
you step back and in business,
we make a point in the
book, which is by the way
Think to Win--
- This is the best.
- Strategic Thinking (mumbles).
- Link that up boys, let's
make sure we link that up.
- Amazon, 23 testimonials from--
- This is awesome.
- With that said, life,
personal, business,
relationships, is about making choices--
- 100%.
- And so there's always choices
to be made, and if you get
your top 2 or 3 priorities
right, the order of magnitude
of the next level of
those kind of choices,
maybe you know, are not as relevant.
- That's right.
- If you try to be too much--
- Too many, you run in to a stone wall.
- Let me close this with
something that I think will
connect with the audience
because it's a truth and
it's something I admire tremendously.
I know this dude very well.
This man's retired, from
the day you retired,
I visit him in Florida and
different things of that
nature, his retirement hustle
is substantially stronger
than a lot of people that I
know's work ethic in their
normal environment.
I look at you and I get
pumped because I'm like
cook, if Peter can retire like
that, which means, oh I don't
know, working all the time,
maybe I can retire like that.
- I wouldn't count it.
- Meaning?
- I just wouldn't count on it.
- Meaning you think I'll lose my passion--
- I don't think that you've
developed the kind of
relationships and networking I have.
- Please.
You really believe it?
Alright, I'm gonna ask you
to ask a question of the day.
If you want to ask this
audience, entrepreneurs,
young millennials, all
ages and shapes, and sizes
but obviously skewing a
little bit younger than you,
what kind of question
would you like to ask them
to answer in the comments,
because I know you love
reading, Peter reads all your comments.
He always wants to jump in.
He like razzes me, he's
like, "You know, Sally
"said you stink."
So, he's paying attention boys and girls.
- One thing I learned over
my entire career in academia
as well as in business,
especially relative to start up
businesses, one to three
year old businesses, working
on big brands at big
companies etc., was at the end
of the day, it came down to
two or three words that I would
always ask when anyone
brought in an idea or a new
ad campaign, new product,
new consumer promotion
idea, a new opportunity
within a company, small,
medium or large, it came
down to two or three words,
and if they could answer
the question in these two
or three words, that went
together by the way, and I'll
tell you right now, the
middle word was and, so you'll
need two more, what would
be your two words that you
think every successful business
needs to be able to address?
- Blank and blank.
I like it, we'll see what you have to say.
- Yea, but the answer is not blank.
- Got it, Peter, I love you.
- Cheers.
- Give me kiss.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(upbeat music)